let's talk about
male birth control because i don't want
to make the show about
slapping um i've seen a lot of stuff
that's popped by my way in the last
couple years on male contraception and
um
it's interesting because there's only
really two forms of male contraception
for men we've got condoms and we've got
vasectomies
arguably the pull out method as well
um for women
some say there's 30 methods i've heard a
dozen
there's more than 10 for sure there's
way more than 10. uh between all the
female hormonal contraceptions the pills
the iuds the carp variety the hormonal
iud the sponges the rings the female
condoms they've got all these different
methods
um and now they're talking about uh
throwing these options out there at guys
and at glance it seems like a great idea
i mean like what guy
you know especially when we talk about
in the red flag chapter to
be in control of birth and not trust
that she's on
birth control because um
we've seen women forget we've also seen
women lie about being on birth control
and guys being on the hook i mean we
know that
when the sperm leaves your nut sac you
have no decision making capacity
whatsoever whatever she says goes and if
she says
you're i need you to pay for the next 20
years for this uh you're on the hook
whether you want it or not
so
um the concept's a great idea i think a
lot of guys would welcome it um given
the fact that you only really have three
choices right now all of which aren't uh
particularly great in any regard you
know i hear a lot of guys who say i'll
just get a vasectomy this time the other
thing and
i've talked to a few of my friends that
have uh had them
and while they won't
generally publicly admit that you know
it feels different it does um you know a
lot of guys are just like yeah it's not
the same but yeah it's effective
um some say it's reversible some say you
know it doesn't really work out that way
there's also some studies that suggest
that vasectomies have some
um consequences later on down the road
um you know with other health concerns
for guys
so yeah i mean why wouldn't you want
male contraceptive that's uh safe and
effective beyond condoms vasectomies are
just pulling out so this is what we have
today we have essentially two pill
options
and an ejection option which i'm going
to share with you
um so let's talk about the and
i'll save the injection option for last
because that involves injecting into
your nut sac
which
i mean like you guys tell me in the
comments when i get to that but hormonal
for guys versus a
what's essentially a vitamin a compound
right
um let me throw this up here on the
screen so let's talk should we talk
hormonal first
let's deal with the hormonal part so
share screen
window
here i don't know why um
these freaking
sites have to
do this where they have these giant
banners all the time
let's see if i can zoom in and push it
out of the way it doesn't really work
anyway so this is a couple here that
participated in the hormonal study and
it's essentially a progestin and
testosterone combo
in this case it was a cream you can see
this nerd over here has this
bottle in his hand
and what he had to do for the trial was
i don't know if he squirts in his hand
or if he just squirts it on his chest
but he basically squirted it from his
chest across to his shoulder
you have to let it absorb in after the
shower and then you can put on your
clothes and proceed with your day now
it's not as simple as that there's some
residue that's left on your skin so
apparently you can't actually get
intimate unless you have a shower before
you do so otherwise the hormones will um
come off your skin onto hers and it can
absorb into her body and she's
essentially taking the same drugs that
you are so there's some delivery issues
with it
um it doesn't seem like they do it in
pill form because it's a progestin which
is essentially what women take for birth
control by the way it's what it's
what'll castrate men
and then they have to top it up with
testosterone
and
anybody that knows anything about uh
testosterone and anabolics knows that if
that if you take a
um a pill that has testosterone in it it
has to pass through your liver and
there's some level of toxicity to your
organs uh more so to your liver so
you don't want that especially on a
long-term basis i mean you can't be
taking a pill that's slowly dissolving
your liver right so they make it in a
cream format it seems or like a gel
format it's probably compounded you
spray you spread it on your your chest
and your shoulders you wait till it
absorbs and and that's basically it the
problem with it though is
it has a 10
uh response rate that's that doesn't
work out
uh reversible
sounds so simple hormonal contraceptive
where's the bit on his feedback on it
uh
do a k okay so for side effects ed who
was a participant says i do occasionally
get hot flashes and night sweats
that doesn't sound like a good thing and
he's gained seven pounds
um that's what you're gonna get with
progesterone you're gonna get a little
bloated you're gonna put on some weight
and you're gonna have some issues with
that the testosterone is designed to
counter that because it shuts down your
body's production so your so your nut
sac doesn't make sperm and then it's
testosterone it's basically trt
it's basically testosterone therapy with
some significant downsides
uh
as for emotional fragility
ed is taken to his mood changes like a
duck to water
um anyway so it doesn't seem like it was
that great of a deal
some of the side effects which i
actually mentioned in the chapter in my
book when it came to a male birth
control pill is it essentially castrates
guys and it turns them into soy boys now
if they don't get the ratio right with
the progesterone and the testosterone um
a lot of the guys in the studies had
experience not a lot but a fair
significant
uh portion of the guys in the studies uh
suffered some side effects which
included lack of libido lack of sex
drive uh erection quality uh lack of
interest in sex um which like what's the
point in taking a male contraceptive if
you can't still enjoy it right like
what's the point so that really hasn't
been working out that well um i found a
video which i should throw up in the
screen actually
stop screen we'll close that one
let me grab this here so this is a video
and
this dude i like he's really good at
distilling
um
concepts when it comes to stuff like
this
and i'm i'm gonna save you the 24 minute
video uh derek for more plates more that
dates basically sums it up over here
just listen to this bit in general um i
don't think it's a good idea personally
like you're basically putting yourself
on trt
to use the progestin you know that's
like that's exactly what you're doing so
if you don't want to be on trt
but don't use it again so
you know sum it up says it's a stupid
idea
from what i've seen with the studies
that i've read in the different articles
it's it's not reasonable so
i mean you want to take that and turn it
into soyboy have fun with it there's
another option with a
non-hormonal component which basically
is designed to block vitamin a in your
knights in your nutsac and
i've queued up a video here that i found
on ted talks
where this dude is talking about how a
male contraceptive pill could work
so it should be queued up let's just
play this
and here we go
like just playback speed a little faster
to block the function of vitamin a in
the testis
let me back it up a tiny bit here
because it queued up the wrong spot
involved the administration of hormones
specifically we are looking to block the
function of vitamin a in the testis
why
well for over 90 years it's been known
that you need vitamin a to make sperm
animals who are deprived of vitamin a in
their diet stop making sperm and restart
making sperm again when the fight so
this is not hormonal this is this is
designed to block an enzyme that
basically tells your nut sac to make
sperm
and
if
the
medical community sorry the medical
community can can
trick the
hormonal cycle to not recognizing
vitamin a in the nutsac then your nutsac
doesn't make sperm seems like a good
idea but just but just listen to this
bit here vitamin a is reintroduced
the vitamin a that we ingest
is converted by a family of enzymes to
something called retinoic acid
one of these enzymes is found only in
the testis it's this enzyme that we are
attempting to block blockade of this
enzyme should deprive the testis of
retinoic acid and stop sperm production
without affecting vitamin a's functions
elsewhere
so
they're saying that it should stop sperm
production without um
affecting vitamin a in the rest of your
body you need vitamin a for normal
functions i mean if they can't get this
right and you've got issues with your
organs uh using vitamin a your skin
your brain all sort of stuff you could
run into some serious issues now i would
imagine they wouldn't put it out if
there was some downstream effects there
but this idea is far better than the
hormonal option and it looks like um
from what i gathered there is a whole
bunch of articles that were put out in
the last three days talking about um
studies moving from animals to humans
now so
you may have a male
birth non-hormonal birth control pill
that you can use in the coming years
the other option which
is just
i don't know who would go for this one
uh let me take this out of stream
and
let's see here scientists are
boom boom boom here we go so let me
share the screen i've got
a little bit more information on this
one
so this proposed kind of contraceptive
let me just zoom this in a little bit
more so you guys can see it
uh the proposed contraceptive is a
product of researchers at the university
of minnesota it says it works by
targeting how our bodies interact with
vitamin a known as the essential
infertility in mammals diets deficient
vitamin a have been linked to sterility
for instance after lengthy search they
found an experimental compound that
blocks a protein responsible for binding
to a form of vitamin a in our cells
known as
retinoic acid receptor alpha rara that's
a cool name rahra
anyway um receptive blocking okay so
this is another follow-up article to
that the other one which is the
injectable
gel
and
this is this company over here it's
called contraline what if a male
contraceptive gave you peace of mind
so
let me just here let me pull this out of
the screen so so i can get a visual of
what the vast deference is where it is
so you guys understand bass
remember this from sex ed in school
uh
the vast deference is a long muscular
tube that travels from
uh
to behind the bladder wow okay so it
basically
it's a long ass tube that goes from your
nut sack
uh and connects to
uh where you deliver
you know the good stuff the boys right
um
for a visual let me put it up on the
screen here
that's a long tube
okay i don't know if you guys can see
that but they would have to essentially
inject
um this is the medical company here
talking about it's called atom atom
trademark they've they've trademarked
the word atom for this
the vas deferens is a pair of tubes that
transport sperm atom it's is a hydrogel
that is inserted inside through a quick
injection now i don't know about you
but
i i like you couldn't pay me enough
money to go to a doctor i don't know
what the injection frequency would be
60 days 90 days 120 days
i can't see a
a dam lasting that long i mean it's
essentially they're damning the tube
right
and they're going to have to put a
needle through your nut sac i mean i
would assume with local anesthetic but
still a needle through your nut sac into
a tube to basically clog it up with this
uh atom gel
um
would you guys there it is right there
so there's a visual representation
so it's effective
99.99 whatever percent at
um
creating a barrier to stop the sperm
from reaching where it needs to go
but uh those are your options guys i
mean if you don't want to deal i mean
this is basically a
chemical
uh vasectomy only temporary that you
have to continue to get injections on
condoms are pulling out those are your
options women have uh
10 20 30 options i don't know they've
got a whole bunch more but those are
your options
would you guys do it
it ain't for me dude i'm not i'm not
going to a doctor to stick a pin in my
nut sack every few months
it just it just doesn't add up set it
and forget it non-hormonal quick easy
checkup that is not an easy a quick easy
checkup you're going to have to go in
they're going to shave your nut sack
you're going to have to local anesthetic
clean it up inject you're going to have
to deal with icing it you've probably
got a day of soreness and pain after
that i can't see that being quick and
easy
set it and forget it for how long
the gel is designed to last at least a
year wow
you're gonna go in there once a year
okay
does not affect hormones procedure is
simple and quick the gel may be imaged a
monitor with an ultrasound so should be
effective
okay so it's a once a year injection
here's brad from boston brad says my
wife lisa has been taking the pill for
12 years and hates it i've looked for
alternative but nothing appealing exists
i'd like something that's reliable and
feels natural lisa 27 also from boston
says brad and i want to start a family
but we're not ready yet we'd like a
temporary solution but i'm tired of the
hormones i'm excited about the promise
of a new male contraceptive
well brad go on in and get your nuts act
uh gelled up hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you